[Musique]
pour la deuxième année consécutive les
qualifications régionales pour le
championnat de danse urbaine bboy france
se déroule est à la merise attrape le
département des yvelines est un
précurseur dans la pratique du
breakdance un espèce d'engouement et
puis une force qui vient de dégainer des
baies 3 1 des black blanc beur voilà il
ya plein de petites associations qui
sont mis à côté a travaillé également
avec différents styles avec différents
événements et puis c'est normal qu'au
niveau territoire il ya un lieu de
diffusion qui sont représentés et
dombasle amoureuse en tout cas leur est
ouverte deux journées de compétition
pour remporter sa place en finale la
semaine suivante dans le nord ce
dimanche place aux juniors et aux piigs
j'essaye de faire une heure
d'entraînement tous les jours et je
révise je fais que réviser et
lors du baptême pas ça mon feeling les
garçons sous tous sont toujours au
devant de la scène ça faut pas se mentir
parce que voilà on va dire qu'ils ont
une place qui est là depuis depuis très
longtemps mais les filles on arrive en
tout cas on arrive et beaucoup
d'organisateurs font en sorte de changer
les choses sur 46 participants elles
étaient dix à concourir en catégorie
bgirl la discipline ces féministes
peuple ça se passe très bien
il faut savoir que le breakdance rentrer
jeux olympiques normalement 2024 à paris
justement et il y aura la catégorie
filles aussi qui sera représentée donc
ça tout va bien aucun evil mois ne s'est
qualifiée chez les filles cécile j eunes
seine et marnaise qui représentera l'île
de france